the Joe Rogan experience retirement is a
relatively new concept is only for the
last like 80 hundred years and you used
to work yourself pretty much and then
you die and I do find that a lot of
people get lost after they give up the
thing and it's a it's a you know it's an
it's kind of a rich kid problem you know
to be a little it's like a sadness
problem people need a task and I think
when people are just waiting around for
death to come knocking on their door
they do get really morose and they just
don't feel good they don't feel
productive so don't deal so one thing
with old people they don't feel helpful
yeah well that's the thing they say the
single best if you're feeling down
generally about yourself the single best
thing they say you could they as though
there's some quorum of they who all
agree on everything but a lot of people
say the single best thing you can do and
this was in our loneliness episode as
well as service helping other people so
do you have you run across anybody that
you've interviewed who you thought had a
great kind of prescription for how to
help other people like doable sensible
you know that if people really like
let's say I say you know I work hard I
try to love the people around me but I
really want to have some kind of service
component but I don't know what to do
that's a good question
I think first start with the people
around you right start telling them you
love them hug them enhance the sense of
community that you share with your
friends and your loved ones
do your best to sort of be the person
who steps forward starts it off
you know like makes an action tell
someone how much you care and appreciate
them
I care about them and appreciate them
when you maybe wouldn't have done that
ordinarily you can do that we can all do
that and we've all had it done to us and
it feels amazing when someone comes up
to you out of nowhere and goes hey man I
just want to tell you I really
appreciate you I know I know sometimes
we don't talk to each other that much
but when I do I really enjoy it I just I
love you give me a hug mmm I just want
you to know yeah I'm very fortunate that
I have a lot of friends that do that
kind of stuff I have a real supportive
group of friends and if you don't you
long for that and I think that's a big
thing I become that person reach out and
try to try to start that I can't imagine
anybody hearing you say that would
disagree it's like such a obviously good
way to be and yet and yet I find that so
many people kind of go out of their way
to not just be generous because they're
scared there's not scarcity there
they think that they have they have to
make it and that if you make it like
zero-sum they're a loser yeah it's
famine thinking it's real real real
complement our hardware is the same and
our software is not yeah and we can
manipulate our hardware we just have to
understand what the patterns are and
also been there you have to make
mistakes you've been there you feel it
you understand what it is and then you
have that time to adjust
that's why losing in life is so
important whether it's getting dumped
getting fired
losing a game loot loss those feelings
where things didn't work out your way
that's important because it lets you
know this is the bad feeling that comes
when it goes wrong and you improve and
then it makes the good feelings of
victory all the better and I mean that
you know in a relative sense like even
getting good at something forget about
victory like making a terrible book that
gets rejected by every publisher and
then writing a really good one and
people accepting like [ __ ] I got better
yes like this thing yeah those feelings
of failure are really critical for your
motivation that's interesting I've
always thought of failure like or like
like a yeah failure or just like a bad
event I've always thought that they were
good because I'm like a scaredy cat in
some ways right and then if the very bad
thing happens the very thing you feared
happens right you survive it and then
you learn to shed more fear in more
directions you know what I mean well so
I could look at it that way look there's
a lot of ways you could look at bad
events you could say a bad event is just
who you are you just have bad events and
you're a [ __ ] loser and life hates
you and God hates you and the hook look
at that happening to Mike again can't
[ __ ] believe it
there's a lot of guys to go through life
like that and you know they could say
that they seek comfort in lowering the
standards that they expect out of things
so when things go bad and they say look
I [ __ ] knew it for them alleviate
some concern about what's gonna happen
in the future because the future is
always [ __ ] so by doing that they've
taken away the fear of exceeding the
fear of overcoming the fear of improving
the fear of getting better as a human
being yeah if you just exhibit the same
patterns you fall into those patterns
whether it's alcoholism or gambling
addiction or sex addiction people
those because they're custom to it it
becomes a normal part of your life I
think that's a scary thing for people to
recognize that they're on a bad pattern
and to say okay I have to stop drinking
how do I dress yes right what what steps
do I make and what's the best way
community yeah they've shown 12-step
programs you get together with some
other guy and he goes look my keistering
too much to where we're just people we
can help each other I'm your sponsor now
and they work together that's and I
think those yeah though that solution is
a really good soul you know I have three
brothers all older I'm the youngest of
eight and I don't mean to disparage them
and I also know you're younger than me
but I kind of wish you'd been my older
brother you would have been really good
maybe I've been sucking up [ __ ] come on
man stop crying yeah that's okay yeah
now that little bit of that one short I
have a sister I don't have a brother but
you know having conversations with your
brothers and sisters sometimes they're
the only people that really know you
like I have conversations with my sister
sometimes she's the only person that
really knows our childhood right we'll
talk about what it was like when were
nine right and do you have the same
perception of events
yeah my sister super honest right and
she's but I mean you remember you
remember yeah yeah yeah yeah she doesn't
distort anything right we both have real
similar recollections of our past so
it's uh but but those people that have
experienced those things with you
they're like the only ones who really
know you deep at your core and the more
things you can experience with people
the more you're gonna share that sort of
but the people that make me sad are the
people that no friends and no confidence
they have no one they could talk to
there's no one that knows their secrets
they have no one that they could tell a
terrible joke to and that you would
never say in mixed company
right you have no one who you know this
especially comedians we're the were
famous for it we say things to each
other all the time that are the hot most
horrible things and just to get a rise
out of each other you know like one of
my friends will say something terrible
to me in my back like about me like
horrible [ __ ] about me and I just think
it's so funny I might do that so that is
what I look like we're so accustomed to
it and there's also in our culture
there's a currency of being able to joke
around like that of course physically if
somebody makes one of my friends makes
to me it's hilarious it's fun we do it
to each other all the time there's
actually like a currency and be able to
take it to like you can make fun of
Andrew he doesn't give a [ __ ] it's not
good but you know that's what people you
know I mean you're in the business and
making fun of things if you're mad at
someone makes fun of you it's not good
in our world
[Applause]